[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
tell the captain's chair because I've
been watching River Monsters lately and
I've gone to the last season he's no
longer in rivers exist in the ocean it's
like you're just hot you're just fishing
for sharks
yeah in the Atlantic Ocean - bull shut
it's that way tune in I wanted to see
River Monsters and fresh water really
excited huge show we have razörfist on
the program yeah yeah dennis prager on
the program oh wow
we will be talking about the media's
double standard with John McCain will of
course be talking about the Facebook
walkout
I got winded from doing the cam here
that's that's a workout apparently I
should say that like in Jaws a captain
is where you're you're bolted into hunt
sharks
well you don't bolt that ins dangerous
though right no you're sick no otherwise
you go overboard what if Tony takes the
boat over
you're like bolted and you're going down
with it and watching tonight that's Jaws
you just said jaws no but it wasn't the
chairs problem all right we're producing
in the show is a quarter black carrot
you can follow on Twitter your quarter
black right yes I am which quarter
uh-huh on your dad say what's that the
hood pass equivalent to us being
murdered in the streets gee Morgan Jr
somehow a apparent let's real thing one
of the day I got acid eree pinot noir my
friend i wonder you see this is almost
like a naked lady on no it's not almost
like and in the third share with us
today is actually isis communications
director and senior public affairs
official Mahmood alma mood how are you
sir Noel Steven good to see you again
I am glad to see you as well you're
sounding a little bit loud to me than
your microphone but that's okay because
our sound guy's gonna gonna get it there
you were breathing into it was a little
loud for you earlier but you know I'm
used to that desert wind
yeah we're here with us today oh you
know I just want to put on a good face
for Isis you know we want you to see the
softer side that's when you're gonna
look at me you don't to look at the
camera you're like no prob where you get
your she can't not look at herself I
know you're I went to media school you
know so I see the professionals I've
seen quite a bit of work and question of
the day put bluntly how do you remember
John McCain all right not what do you
feel you have to remember not what do
you think everyone wants you to say you
remember how do you view him in his
legacy comment below we'll get into the
media's flip-flop comparing McCain to
Nazis before - hailing him as the second
coming of Christ in a minute but our top
story these recently took over a hotdog
stand on Times Square New York
this comes to us from an actual
publication the bees engulfed a food
carton were carefully removed from the
umbrella well some stray bees made their
way to the facade of a nearby cafe
unfortunately the swarm actually proved
to be fatal as some just looking to
enjoy New York hotdog were taken from us
far too soon necessarily dark my mom let
me watch that when I was 7 let you watch
anything from the West you know what I'm
really surprised is that the bee
survived the hot dog water from those
things I mean come on are people like al
Mamoon a facebook employee is now
starting a movement against the
company's intolerant liberal culture as
he puts it and a lot of people have
joined the engineer Brian I'm Mary I
think it's a marriage a I don't know is
one of things I've only read about yeah
it happens again in media only online on
sites that we read alleges that
colleagues attack often in mobs anyone
who's not left-leaning
he says they tear down Trump posters and
demand that HR investigate anyone who
criticizes Islam's human rights records
amen brother
come on so this is our liberal tech
bloggers are concerned this is going to
allow conservatives to claim big tech is
bias against them well conservatives are
concerned about big tech being biased
against them by the way jeez was the
original whistleblower try to ask you
you can't because he was murdered yeah
it's tragic for voting for John McCain
Oh whom we all love dear of course now
by the way you know the original
investigator yeah for the whole thing
was a Tom from MySpace oh yeah but we
had him burned in a cage yeah seems to
be the method that you guys use what's
it's getting cliche
and I didn't look don't worry we're
gonna we're gonna give you the update
story when they summarily fire him for
sexual harassment later on yes so don't
worry about that yeah it's gonna be a
random case from five years ago was just
copy pasted from Fox News yes
the point is someone's getting Wiener
pics from a co-host you guys pioneered
the the burning in a cage really why the
cage it seems incidental like that the
burning should be bad necessary right no
it's kind of theatrical you know there's
something about a cage that evokes
something I don't know if it's primal it
works it just works right I don't know
what about the acid attacks why that
because you know there's one thing I've
never understood you know you shoot
someone you stab someone understand it's
war you're trying you're trying to take
somebody out the acid attack I mean it
you know you're not gonna kill them it's
just unpleasant you know it's in the
kitchen of your mom
you have you have acids in the kitchen
of your mom and you know you make do you
know this is a right so it's like the
Bart Simpson's little bastards yeah yes
the foundation of many art forms really
yeah I don't think so at all I think
you're entirely mistaken but you know
listen cultural differences turning to
Canada speaking of cultural differences
Toronto is going to be opening its first
sex doll brothel oh yeah yeah Anna
nondescript shopping plaza so it's the
company's marketing director gonna break
out this quote that said that there will
be no human staff in the brothel brothel
section and goes on to say that for men
who have these dark violent fantasies
they can do something like this which is
safe for everyone they said and trust us
you don't want to bark up that tree said
Tonka the fing toy maker of the early
ill-fated 90s buddies
buddy hey fellas what's going on nothing
buddy's new from Tonga he sold
separately I don't know why I heard
about those sex dolls though a buddy of
mine but he bought 72 of them City put
off eBay afterwards slightly used that
was them yeah I don't know the terms of
service I think there was a little flag
about this yeah I can you're the worst
job in the world the IT guy we know
there's the Pratt the level of depravity
with center dolls right we know that
we've reached that level de prepped but
now we've also we've created this
ungodly amalgamation this this
combination this symbiotic relationship
of the sexual depravity and laziness
they're not even earning the sex dolls
now it's Elise I wouldn't want to be the
guy that has to go in there with the
squeegee and the wet wipes on each one
of those we've seem to have created a
real live West world thank God we needed
one of those right I just worked out so
well on the show I don't think Evan
Rachel Wood well I think there's much
sadder than well this is definitely the
questworld season to where it sucks at
the end there's no getting to the center
of the game this would make a good dirty
jobs that would be awesome you guys get
there where you are in your own yeah and
your layer it pirates you got dirty jobs
in your lair big fans of the micro oh
yeah we have the satellite oh yeah oh
yeah he's drinking from the infidels mug
over there he must be a fan now we it
with fire the contractual obligation
even know it's in here
sleep tight finally there's new data by
the way on a New York City Subway
masturbator
so the NYPD field at a total 376 reports
of public lewdness
or exposure of a person last year and
they log 24 complaints at stations
served solely by the F train of course
more than any other shows which actually
finally gave authorities evidence needed
to arrest Thomas a serial public
masturbator Tank Engine so they were
real
I knew that Grimm it was like like Al
Capone they caught him on something else
note they caught him on he went off the
rails that's what happened it's not only
hearing coming down and coming down the
coming down I think I can rape and
should by the way you should have seen
the D train oh my god Oh nobody wants to
see never caught in a train no but no
speaking of loneliness by the way
because that Trina's do you remember
shining time station am I the only one
out there please comment time station
did you ever watch reading time station
there must have been a Canadian shop so
this is Thomas Thomas the Tank is a
train and is it Thomas the Tank it's
Thomas our train it's offered Thomas the
Tank Engine how mr. Tank Engine almost
you think it's disturbing that you know
that I know I do must study ones
opponent namely six-year-old boys yes
yeah so a shining time station tell me I
don't know if this was a Canadian thing
it was a it was like a mr. kind of like
a Mister Rogers neighborhood only was at
a train station and pink pinky whatever
her name was from Greece she was a lady
who ran the train station and there was
actually a little conductor a little
mini conductor on the table people gonna
think I'm on acid I'm not a story this
is an actual show that you are on and
that mini conductor was George Carlin
and they would say uh-oh
have you ever heard the story of my
friend Thomas the Tank all aboard it'll
go to smoke and it would go to a story
of Thomas the Tank Engine and that's
where it started so I know where I see
the Thomas Tank Engine stuff every what
I'm wondering if people know we don't
call it that because he'll train it's
not a tank
shining time station was the show and
they replaced George Carlin like in a
third season with Ringo Starr I know
he'll think I'm on drugs
probably because George Carlin woke up
one morning said I'm George Carlin this
may have been a dream you had this is
Canadians out there shining time station
no madam mr. Drebin I wonder it sounds
like a complex pedophile ring you would
have experience with that wouldn't you
sir oh well I did I did watch it in the
bottom of a pizza parlor so I feel very
low speaking of loneliness actually you
know what's being called as Holy Grail
weight loss drug has been for a while
now it's finally found to be safe in an
obesity study scientists found Laura
Catherine did not raise the risk of
cardiovascular problems among at-risk
individuals who took part in the
clinical trial
though the authors of the study
acknowledged that lifestyle changes are
actually the recommended way to lose
weight which may sound like a mix of
message but it here you know just take a
look at their commercial when it comes
to the things you love most is your
weight getting in the way are your
favourite indulgences followed by
needless feelings of crippling guilt do
you find yourself not getting the same
joy from your ones favorite pastimes it
may not be your fault you may be
suffering from chronic mild to moderate
fatness but you're not alone it is
estimated that 50 to 65 percent of
Americans suffer from moderate to severe
fat goodness the good news is lore
Catherine can help in a recent clinical
trial Laura Catherine reduced fatness
and its symptoms by over 50% compared
with placebo along with improved weight
loss BMI as well as other auxilary
health parameters so ask your doctor
today side effects may include a
continued lack of discipline inflated
sense of self-esteem poor eating habits
rebound weight gain future diabetes
phantom neuropathy and feminism do not
take lore Catherine if you are pregnant
may become pregnant or are thinking
about pregnancy and or the continuation
of your bloodline at all
lore Catherine so you can be at your fat
best
you really have that many big people in
where you come from because it's not
yeah I've cut people's heads off but
that was disgusting give us a miracle
advice for you to get your fat ass to
the gym put the Cheetos down you're
welcome - excellent you know you think
there are people obviously who have
genetic inclination yes see more
overweight I understand that that's not
40% of the population no but if there's
a drug that works God love them I guess
we keep coming up with all these complex
ways to kill you it's been carbs the
whole time and we get pissed off at you
for burning people it's we do it
ourselves all be burning the calories by
the way hit the notification bail
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot anymore on the YouTube and join my
club if you want to watch the show every
day it's an hour long and of course it's
what helps us fight back against the
YouTube overlords nine ten dollars a
year six and n if your student veteran
active military and something else I
want to announce we're going to be doing
a segment for those who are mug Club
members life advice with steven crowder
some of you have asked for it so send
your requests your questions sort of a
Dear Abby but you know I'm a dick life
advice at louder when Strider comm life
advice at letters credit calm and we'll
be doing whole shows just reading your
reading your letters and awesome solving
your problem okay so back to the story
obviously this this is this is dominated
the news this week here's here's what
really bothers me about the McCain issue
there's a pattern as it relates to both
McCain and President Trump the media of
course the excoriate any conservative
any Republican on a national platform no
matter who they are and what they always
do is they use that to enact as though
they only have a problem with recent
extremists right yeah they do that all -
all the time and a lot of people just
forget about and going oh yeah I guess I
guess so no I guess they were pretty
fair with George Bush I guess they're
pretty fair with McCain I guess I'm
pretty fair with Romney it's just it's
just Donald Trump that they don't like
yeah exactly
do they have to like make up for it in
the end they're like I we were really
jerks for this guy oh he's dead let's
let's like do an hour's worth of good
coverage that that evens it out when
everyone is Hitler no one is so exactly
well let's look at John McCain the media
has been pumping out hero stories of
McCain obviously since his death and
most of them obviously well warranted
the guy was a war hero but the media
completely despised him for the longest
time just because he was a candidate
against Barack Obama if you didn't get
any proof you
any examples haven't seen anyone put
this side-by-side so I want you to see
the exact same people what they said pre
and then post McCain death because all I
want is consistency here and I'll get to
my opinion on them a little bit in a
little minute it's going to sound harsh
but I'm not going to lie to you so let's
go to exhibit a light night hosts left
wing pundits let's look how they this is
how they felt about McCain while he was
alive and look like to say one thing to
Senator John McCain listen listen
senator you don't show up for me America
doesn't show up for you but we like
Obama because who he can lift a
basketball and and Obama can bite into
an apple and he's on the Internet and
he's on my face this just doesn't smell
right because this is not the way a
tested hero behaves you sir are
responsible for a phalanx of individuals
who are shouting fire in a crowded
theater what is what is left always go
to fire in a crowded course with the
free speech and it was ascending with
McCain everything bad isn't going on it
I can't have going through my mental
rolodex sir I've already used Nazi and
fascist and fire in a crowded do it
again I have no idea but what's what are
your folks how they feel about the
McCain oh you know they have a lot of
respect for John McCain you know he he
he stood up the torture you know
Vietnamese torture he could handle that
I mean to be honest I can't even put up
with a Vietnamese hospitality I can the
torture was positively it was child's
play compared what you guys do nothing
but then here's a thing they did but
then as soon as McCain just became a
little bit of a Bob a little bit of a
thorn in Trump's side my favorite person
in politics in American politics in the
21st century is your father by the look
at the eye line there my favorite person
is your father not awkward at all I
think he made John McCain worst worst
person in the world several times yeah
it's it's how disingenuous are at Bob's
we love McCain hate McCain I couldn't
care less just be honest about it and
Keith Oberman obviously well hopefully
he pays you guys a visit sooner you pay
him
that would be great I like the anger I
like angry Keith yes it's much better
than I've got a thrill running up my leg
Keith look I don't understand you know
when somebody dies like you're not
supposed to speak ill of the Dead I
don't know that I think that originated
like 600 BC somewhere and they I don't
know why it's not like you've
accomplished a feat this is exactly what
Freud said we give you special
consideration is that you've done
something really difficult death has a
perfect record except for it you know
that one guy yeah so why in the world do
we not just tell people the truth and
even with that one guy death had a
no-contest
well that's necessarily what to do with
McCain is exactly what they're doing to
Trump people because he's dead now
people acting's others there you cannot
delineate at all they use every single
left to strategy in the book well not
see mentally unfit racist white
supremacist Satan homophobe all of that
sound all of that sound familiar does
any of that sound like the kind of
nomenclature hearing today you hear this
obviously I were you are you hear these
words thrown at Donald Trump you know I
I do seem pretty calm and I think it's
because they're effective we do some of
the things also rocks yes you do throw
those around a lot you know it's more
effective than rocks
the IDF yeah
[Laughter]
no nonsense I appreciate that I hate
that he has the address to our studio at
least McCain wasn't at least McCain
wealth and I Nazi right like Trump yeah
because that's only a recent spear
except remember this yeah there's
something on here that's a comedy show
but it was commonly people were getting
their cars their windows broken for
McCain bumper stickers and you know my
brother had someone tear off his sign
well because if you were for McCain you
were a racist in a Nazi against Barack
Obama yeah there's nothing to do with
the FSK efficacy of him or not right
well that was a member back then it was
racist was even bigger than now yo he as
it was Barack Obama and then when I was
hill trained Donald Trump it was sexist
sexist and they tried to throw the whole
trans folk thing in there because it
kind of fit under the umbrella of gender
and you realize what a second aha I went
from everyone from races today no she's
just a bit that's it's a pretty
straightforward thing as a matter you
kind of have to be to lose to Donald
Trump at that moment Orion people won't
you you will not appreciate just how
unlikely it was for Donald Trump to win
if anyone else outside of Hillary I
don't get me wrong I'm glad that I'm
glad that it happened but I mean you
guys even had it did you have a dog in
that fight at that point I wagered hard
on Hillary of course in trade yeah you
were looking for the research I put it
all on everyone was there ever it was at
New York Times we were doing the live
election 98% oh it's it was watch the
numbers go down while we did that stream
it was in their face yeah it was
fantastic
I love the tears still see them the
point is this isn't unique to McCain
specifically okay let's specifically the
person right after McCain yeah remember
Obama mocking Romney for what for what
now for what what was a bombing enemy
number one now Russia when you asked
what's the biggest geopolitical threat
facing America you said Russia not
al-qaeda you said Russia and the 1980s
are now calling to ask for their foreign
policy back by the way quarterblack
called he wants his melanin back right
so yeah he says I want the birth
certificate just to see if you're more
than I don't think we're buying it
that's what are the other three quarters
[Laughter]
no you guys won't let him live either
way so what does it matter to you so
March 2014 Russia annexes right the
politely steals back a country for a
Crimea it's no big deal Russia's not a
problem and then July 2018 Trump meets
with Putin and all the sudden it's
collusion it I know yes
Trump you realize that we armed
Ukrainians they killed over 100 Russian
soldiers like you're aware you wear
their policies actually a lot more harsh
on Russia outside of President Obama
that's the thing now everyone is
concerned about Russia back then we were
Russia whatever he thinks Russia's a
threat and how many times have you heard
people not even even Bill Maher said
well at least Mitt Romney was a decent
person they changed their stance once
the person is no longer a threat
and it's the same playbook by the way
that's been used over and over
not just one or two every now and then
McCain was no exception because it's
been used on every single conservative
or republican ever even the seamless
mutuality of government and big business
come out and say it there is a
dictionary definition one word that
describes that toxic blend you are a
fascist the biggest joke of the day is
not communism it's moving America toward
a fascist theocracy George Bush doesn't
care about black people we put that one
in just because I know everyone's on the
Kanye transfer that you don't see the
rest of the clip is my is Meyers
reaction I don't everybody oh yeah this
is going you put me next to the touched
black guy who thinks he's Freddie
Mercury for some reason what a crappy
listen my thoughts in my purse of course
go out to the McCain family and lose
losing a family member and listen for
better or worse where whatever your
opinion a national icon yeah it's always
a tragedy there's a time for Mourning
but all I'm talking about here is a
little bit just a modicum of consistency
how do I remember remember McCain okay
how do you remember McCain you guys I
remember McCain is somebody who I hate
to say this again he's dead it became a
pansy politically speaking he just down
stand up for anything anymore and it's
it seems like he's switched to try to
just gain popularity exactly okay so I
remember him as the only thing I
remember him like honestly well it's
terrible I hate a vietnam war camp you
okay we're a black-haired that's like
they're also race that really all of a
sudden you'd be like you'd be like Peter
denying Christ three times before the
rooster crows and eyeing your blackness
right oh they're not fond of you guys
true I think that the cane is a good I
don't know that that's true at all watch
that's probably the term I don't know
what they say they don't got the memo
how dare you yet people you want me to
change that now african-american
what-have-you from Jamaica in Canada you
stupid
so I don't remember john mccain good man
yeah absolutely member is a good man and
a candidate that I didn't like but voted
for because I had to I had no choice and
someone who despite his unbelievably
impressive military pedigree surprised
me yeah with some of his caving to
political peer pressure in Washington
and by the way you know what
nearly everyone out there listening
right now watching feels the exact same
way that we just mentioned about McCain
you just don't think you can say it
that's it almost everyone you talk to
you like yeah McCain we kind of screwed
the pooch with McCain listen you don't
have to love the guy because he's dead
now I think the guy is worthy of more
respect than some people out there like
Ted Kennedy who killed the girl
I would honor John McCain before that
but it does me they love everything
about the guy in none of that changes by
the way when I die please the people who
hate me don't change your tune shout it
from the roof the Rick hola guy okay
and with my body so we don't I don't
care I don't care what she asked me if
it's open casket cuz French Canadians do
that and cremation just leave me out for
the trash on Tuesday it's done noted
willing beheading post-mortem
nonetheless so the one thing that's
beyond dispute I think here was a
passing McKenna it proves to us time and
time again yet how many times of us is
that the appeasing crocodiles is futile
yeah doesn't matter how moderate you are
doesn't matter how much middle ground
you try to find or concede that's why I
couldn't care less about middle ground I
couldn't care less about finding common
ground I care about truth once you're at
the top of the heap for the Republican
Party or even seen as any kind of a
concern of representative you will get
the same playbook play to get Nazi
racist homophobe bigot war hawk liar
dummy take your pick so live your life
and be exactly who you are be your
right-wing self to the fullest because
the only time the left will ever treat
you with any respect or civility that's
the term of the day now rights if you
don't ever give you any respect or
civility is when you can be used as a
political pawn once you're dead
razörfist Dennis Prager coming on
oh hello there
Mahmoud here to tell you about mug Club
and why you should not join it mclubbe
is horrible it's called how much does it
cost even it's it's actually pretty good
deals $99 a year 69 for veterans $99 69
for students veterans or military what
is that in lira I couldn't tell you
you're the one who wanted to do the read
this you said your media school
experience or is gonna help you okay
look that's a lot of money you should
not do it come on it's what is it blue
you probably have a blue cup and it's
it's a what do you get with it it's hand
etched good mug feel it feel run your
finger across it there wow that is handy
I get the show every single day they
also get all the see our TV catalog they
get the mug yeah they get there's
there's like 10 15 programs they get
access to its whole network yeah but how
many sandwiches as well I don't really
get anything which is at all don't get I
just very hungry we really should have
put you in a flight that had meal
service a lot of credit calm slash mug
Club today
don't listen to him
[Music]
it is fly I don't know what that means I
don't know what that means if people say
it's fly or when people say in Canada
teach to say it's jokes yeah that wasn't
I would say that isn't the Canadian
thing like it's funny but they would say
it's jokes don't like a whole lot of
Center through it with their ad verbage
over there someone who is very eloquent
in the way he speaks and he also has a
new merch store up I believe I didn't
even know that it's always hard to plug
him because well we'll just go with that
will continue with said and show off
something I say there it's it's the
rageaholic on youtube but then a
razörfist
on the Twitter with as with a zero so
most of you will get that wrong mr. fist
how are you sir I always I try to make
it as confusing as buying a ps4 yes I'm
not in such a spell what's a gamer the
game gamer said but I assume it's
difficult to purchase a Playstation 4
yes there's about 50 different versions
now or any console really it's not just
ps4 pretty much anything I see I didn't
know the last time I was playing was was
a Goldeneye Nintendo 64 and then I had
an Xbox which my mom traded for a
television set for her kitchen
unbeknown I going to many Madden events
no I am your future I am NOT which okay
so as a gamer I didn't want to get your
take on this you know he's been he's
been dubbed the Madden shooter I'm sure
you've heard this I have to stop you
look like when I heard there was a John
Madden shooting like who among us didn't
hope you know what I mean like a joke to
be joked organized to be relatable I
don't know that that many people have a
deeply seeded hatred for John head and I
think it might go off the rage I love
John but come on no that's when I well I
it is one of those issues kind of like
the trans stories it's very difficult to
read you know this is a he to she and
because I never actually want to they
never want to show you their cards like
just assume this is actually a man or a
woman
well who's winning the state wrestling
titles I can't tell same thing can
happen some people when they read the
mad and shooter thought oh no what
happened to John
but yeah what's your take on this that
this has been kind of a part of the
vernacular turn deed yeah it's turned
into a facet of the gun control argument
basically and now only now it's video
game control basically who who thought
when you start banning inanimate objects
that they wouldn't stop at guns yes
would have thought when it's no longer
than a man object it's no longer a
cd-rom it stronger a cartridge it's just
a game that's download on an iPad
nebulous cloud somewhere yeah alongside
Jennifer Lawrence's breasts pictures
yeah so basically because some barely is
functional you know sperg decided turn
Madden into a first-person shooter
we're back on the the you know blame
videogames bandwagon yeah you know never
my and
if you look at it statistically video
game adoption is it an all-time high
while violent street crime is at an
all-time low or it's at like a 40-year
lower so I'm such you never mind that
you know the two numbers are basically
arcing in opposite direction let's let's
blame Luigi for Columbine you know I
mean like it it just doesn't make any
sense at all and the real problem like
no issue exposes the cognitive
dissonance of sort of the slack tvoaqui
dichotomy between reflexively defending
video games as inanimate objects that
lack destructive agency as I'm sure we
all agree while calling for the
regulation or outright ban of firearms
in spite of the very same like Eddie if
you want hours of entertainment just
point out the self event contradiction
and just watch him lock up like Obama
without a prompter that being said after
the incredibly disappointing launch of
the Gamecube with Luigi's Mansion I did
want to blow my brains out so I'm sure
there's some there's some runoff there
he's not entirely clean he's not a
spotless lamb as it were yeah it is odd
that they you go go Madden you know
remember when we were growing up it was
doom and Duke Nukem and then Goldeneye
and then call of duty was when Madden no
kidding and that's the thing like it's
like they want to they want to have the
government banned certain thing they
just want a cherry-pick is basically the
long and short of it I mean
basically they're learning you let the
government slide just the tip in they'll
be up to their elbows in plugging
everyone else here's here's the deal
though um you know the NRA came out and
blamed videogames so that's what really
bothers me is when people on the right
try to do this as well to help you skate
the issue because when all huh we want
to get them off the scent of guns like
well you don't need to you have the
Second Amendment guys you don't have to
blame Medal of Honor by the way no one
plays it anymore
um but you talk about banning things
selectively yeah we were just talking
about this before he wanted to ban mixed
martial arts as human cockfighting you
know John McCain was somebody who was
very selective and what he wanted to ban
when he wanted to be big government
versus small government and I know we're
not supposed to talk about it like I
said I remember John McCain Senator John
McCain is a guy I had to vote for decent
man uh waffled to the Democrats when he
didn't have to and was kind of a
politician that's about how I view as
almost everybody does but no one feels
they can say it as someone who spent a
lot of time in Arizona likely more than
McCain before his a political career
what are your thoughts on on this right
now sorry I was holding a moment of
silence for the tumor I just
disclaimer he's my senator I'll say all
the things you want to say but can't
here's the thing I don't dis there are
some people who dislike him because you
know on the Trump side that's not why
but I did you know upholding Obamacare
for example it still pisses me off
alive or dead that doesn't change I mean
I did do a video the day Ted Kennedy
died sketch the ghost of Ted Kennedy so
I have no problem with it I just want
people to be consistent and honest
that's my favorite thing by the way
about Mitt Romney criticizing Trump for
a lacking decorum you know and oh no
like criticizing him for corruption over
the funding gate you know campaign
funding gate it's like you're from
Massachusetts my friend your state bird
is an Oldsmobile in a lake and you're
gonna talk to me about about corruption
come on but no look I'm in Arizona he's
my senator he still is actually we don't
have an appointee so I guess his corpse
is my senator
IIIi literally have not had a senator
for the last two years because John
McCain was too busy playing politics
from his deathbed to resign
you know while Jeff Flake went on safari
to avoid voting hon she basically that's
my primary issue is the obfuscation and
the BS around his condition his ability
to actually work the fact that for the
last year we basically have not been
represented at all in the Senate you
know yeah and another thing like you'd
think dying a brain sickness would take
a bite out of your spite but apparently
not so much you know he was uninviting
people from his funeral to the bitter
end he uninvite strum he uninvite slam
Paul calls him a Russian agent and it
fights yet Halon the woman he ran with
in 2008 I know I know it is it is one of
the your you'd like to think he wouldn't
be a bitter old person but it really
seemed when you look at that list of
people for people who haven't it
actually it gets worse I think if you
look down the list there's some that are
strikingly personal somebody was
explaining it to me because he can't
know necessarily everyone it's not
invite list it's like a bookings to read
as a child is called Hooper Humperdinck
not Heyman was just about people who
weren't invited to the party there are
mostly losers and fat people it's how I
learned my ABC's not a joke but we were
this is important that someone from at
Arizona has come on the show to talk
about this because we were talking about
the left and the left obviously now
saying well listen he was one of the
greatest American heroes they called him
a Nazi back then we just ran a clip from
Family Guy where they showed the SS with
a mccain-palin sticker this is what
bothers me about the left but we're not
hearing a lot of folks on the right talk
about some of these issues as well
there's the inconsistency issue which
we've dealt with but I think that your
some of your comments barring the others
that I cannot condone or eliminate right
and the thing is like you I think part
of it is number one she associated too
closely with Trump and two I think he
kind of always blamed her for losing the
election yes Keith I like even if he had
invited her he would have had to pull
her out from under the bus first you
know what I mean like I and here's the
thing if you go back through that
campaign and really look at the high
points and low points like I can
pinpoint the precise moment McCain
cratered that election right and I can
do it in exactly one sentence are you
ready King
humming my French Jewish coming right
yeah like I bet at that exact moment
Obama was coming yeah there's there's
the quintessential archetype for
progress and change you know a haggard
old Jim Henson Creature Shop character
it looks like he's about to brew a
potion and the Dark Crystal like a dude
who's kept alive with Egyptian magic
let's put him on stage next to the young
handsome smiling black dude there's you
know there's a recipe for Republican
victory positioning himself as the
candidate of change we'll see that was
the Illuminati sleight of hand or that
the sleight of hand there just occurred
right there John McCain is so white you
didn't realize that President Obama
doesn't even pass the brown paper bag
test so he's really not that black it
was just a contrast the Illuminati by
the way they meet on Tuesdays no I think
you're I think you're right and also if
this is important a lot of people don't
realize when we talk about finding
common ground or reaching across the
aisle we were just talking about the
video game issue a lot of people don't
remember this I thought it was
Republicans and conservative Christians
who wanted to bend South Park I was at
UT and I spoke actually with I was
tricked raced under Matt Parker Trey
Parker Matt stone Matt stone and he said
Christians never actually wanted to ban
us they just want us to some later time
slot which we were fine with if you go
back to the censorship in the 90s it was
spearheaded by tipper gore that's
something a lot of people don't remember
the rating systems and the warning
labels and it was something that John
McCain I don't remember exactly not
entirely but a lot a lot of steps along
the way got on board with this and
that's just not a conservative thing to
do regardless but for your libertarian
if you're a populist if you're a
traditional conservative
constitutionalist you're not on board
with silencing what people can and
cannot act yeah and it was he would
usually jump on those issues when they
became populist once right that's the
the great misnomer about John McCain is
this idea that he was a maverick really
he was a Politico he was a guy who would
yellow with the wind whichever direction
the breeze was blowing he would blow
there and then afterward when it was
unpopular he'd say sorry guys I'm a
maverick yeah you know that's kind of
the issue with John McCain talk to me
goose just don't let him take off from
the aircraft carrier but anyway no
that's difficult a big problem like at
the end of this is a horrible segment I
hope you realize this I hope you
understand that this is my work in the
gaming community this will not go over
well but I'll allow it
[Laughter]
the entirely our fault no I do agree
that the Maverick thing is this was it
was branding it was branding it wasn't
really consistent with the guys values
and I just you know I don't think that I
dislike the guy as much as you do
because largely because I'm not from
Arizona and in spending time you know in
Michigan or spending time you know in
Texas where a lot of people are really
happy with Ted Cruz there's a big
contrast right you look at the general
and Donald Trump was calling him lyin
Ted and people in Texas were going okay
we get this is a general it's like
pre-fight hype but we want this guy in
that Senate seat he's actually done a
pretty good job it's the exact opposite
with small government voters in Arizona
with McCain I think it's a story that
needs to be told yeah and yet it's
bizarre because like it's crazy this
state I don't know what he did like at
the end of the day God voted him out of
office before we die I said that
somewhat humorously I did but at the end
of the day like you know the entire
electorate he called the crazies during
the 2016 election he called his entire
electorate and every I don't understand
every said the McCain The Situation's
about you know your video I know that
you put up on the subject term limits
that is an issue you are talking about
guy who's a career politician win lose
or draw obviously it's always a tragedy
when someone has lost who's an American
icon you know for better or for worse
wherever people line up whether it's the
left or the right and I don't know who
lines up where now it seemed like the
left just absolutely loves John McCain
and it seems as though many people on
the right are horribly I don't know what
to make of it but it's always a tragedy
but I think we also need to be honest
and consistent ok razörfist where's the
best pleasure - laughs I know it's
rageaholic on YouTube where's your new
merch store let's plug that before we go
we're thats going to be opening so I'll
have more announcements about that going
forward the best way to find those will
be twitter.com slash razörfist with a
zero and of course there are links to
everything else there so that'll be the
easiest way to beard me there you go and
he will be back
before you know it loving you with more
more plugs than Joe Biden over there
yeah act actually significantly more
people don't realize this to help at one
of my favorite stories ever is on the
Amtrak magazine I'm taking the Joe Biden
Express and someone clearly put a
picture of him when he was young and
bald and then a picture of him old with
a full head of hair right next to each
other I'm going I love the senior editor
of this magazine have to go at razörfist
dennis prager next John came though
whenever oh you it off I heard you were
a Pio w literally five thousand times
CNN called you a monster
even after you had cancer in your brain
they compared you to Hitler
it's a spit upon your name now the city
media said you live your life like a
hero without sin only praised you
moments after your rigor mortis set in
and they never got to know you cuz you
are a Republican and the only good rib
of again
to the media is dead
the blood John McCain no one ever knew
you it all I heard you a repeal W like
five thousand times good night sweet
prince
[Music]
that's called the my producer Johnny boy
brought this in reckon I was going
where's the physical copy of our next
guest book we can just do it huh but now
I've got it of course you guys know
Exodus this is the the rationale Bible
and there's it's a series actually as
far as I understood right now but I
highly recommend this you can buy it
wherever books are sold that's mainly
online now let's be honest not a lot of
people are I went to a Barnes & Noble
it's a cafe
yeah it's called Barnes & Noble cafe and
they also happen to sell books but a
quarter of a library radio host author
founder of Prager University you know
him you love him mr. Dennis Prager how
are you sir
I know you and I love you too and I mean
it
stop it you do great work well thank you
thank you very much and I was very proud
I was recognized at a cigar lounge on
not too long ago when people said we
were watching your interview with Dennis
Prager today it seems like a lot of
conservatives hang out up those places
and they really enjoyed the chat yeah
well do you know by the way I do a
fireside chat every week on the on
Facebook for Prager you from my home
yeah and I smoked a cigar it was we were
not a lot of promo at last week on
Facebook because I smoked a cigar
yes of course not but you can you can
use their weed finding app it's very
effective it really is I think there was
actually they wouldn't allow the cigar
aficionado if I'm not mistaken or was a
cigar lounge finder app on Apple because
it involved any tobacco product no no
yeah I think I think it got fixed
I think it got fixed but it was a long
drawn-out battle before we go into
something I want to talk with you about
you are you were just educating me off
air [ __ ] octa is what I thought it is
it's Yiddish for screwed up right
screwed up basically yeah I don't want
to tell you literally what it is but yes
it sounds it actually seems like a much
cleaner word than it sounds like but
apparently not so you're right
you're turning out obviously a ton of
videos at Prager you I shouldn't say a
ton a really good amount of high quality
videos ton makes it sound like it's a
factory and I I know I actually be in
Los Angeles to do another video with you
guys soon you recently did
where you just specifically let people
in on your history your worldview how
you came to be who you are
it was unique in comparison to a lot of
other pregger you videos now I'm
familiar with your history because I
used to pirate radio like I've talked
about from Plattsburgh New York we
didn't have it in Montreal why did you
feel the need to do that though with
with pregger you well it was it was not
my idea actually III would not have
suggested it but we just had a big
birthday party for me 300 folks spent a
lot of money to come to a big hotel in
Beverly Hills they came from around the
country it was a very sweet guy I don't
like that stuff but it really turned out
to be a great evening and Alan Esther in
my producer and the guy whose idea
Praeger you was was made a video to show
at this big thing and that about my life
I didn't even know he did it I had no
hand in it I did it's the only preview
video I didn't edit and our our CEO said
you know what Pete not everybody knows
Dennis now on even people who know
they'll know anything really about his
life so why don't we just put it up once
and that's how it happened well you say
edit you mean creatively edit you're not
sitting there with a mouse and Final Cut
Pro exactly oh yeah you're talking about
the video or the I'm talking about the
both by the way yes
actually I don't [ __ ] with Final Cut Pro
right but yes I do I have the I I'm the
final writing editor of the videos and
and the final video editor yes yes I
mean I mean you're doing the creative
and it just as a director what we're
seeing it just morally I have to be
because it's called Prager you it was
all Brian you then no Brian would be the
final yes I know and I remember the last
time I went and I had to go through many
many edits which is why there's this
show and then you see me nice and
cleaned up at Prager you as far as you
know a shave and I look at every I
walked this is a funny story told al
Allen your producer was there and it
took me a long time to explain to him
what the Swedish bikini team was because
we were doing a video on it wouldn't
take a minute to explain it to me
exactly
I don't think you think I don't think
anyone knows what the Swedish bikini
team is I'm like everyone knows what
this week that's what they're known for
is IQ and bikini by the way if there is
someone in my life who would not know it
is Alan Alan is is close to sainthood as
anyone I work with well that's perfect
so he's like you're Game of Thrones
eunuch you know that you can trust him
around all the women no but like the guy
in your Thrones who's bald and he's like
I'm just playing the game and turning
everyone against each other I can't
stand that guy but my he is cunning um
so listen any updates on the the battle
that you've been having with with you
two I know you've been at the front I
don't notice you've been at the
forefront of the sensor should the
cultural censorship online are there any
developments he can tell us about I know
legally yes yes well interestingly we
had two two of videos that were that
they that that was their band
essentially a bye-bye Facebook oh
they're Sony means Facebook right it is
exactly and we we called them on it and
and it made world news is a big BBC
piece on Facebook apologizes to Prager
you yeah so but the there's also the
shadow banning issue where you think you
put it up but it's not going anywhere so
you're not fully aware of the fact that
not people aren't seeing it look it has
become importantly a it should be one of
the most important to three issues in
the country right there never in the
history of the world have so few people
controlled all information for humanity
as a Google YouTube Facebook so if they
are politically motivated then we're
we're in real trouble by the way did you
see this was amazing the New York Times
even had a piece on this one hundred
people I believe it was Facebook
Facebook yeah yes that's a big deal
that is a big deal hey wait
we're not a left-wing group we're
supposed to be neutral yeah well I don't
know how familiar are with my history
with Facebook but my half-asian lawyer
bill Richman who's now on retainer and a
part of the show the way I met him was
there was an article at Engadget or
TechCrunch one of these tech sites with
a list that was released it was leaked a
list of people to throttle on Facebook
and it was you know Ted Cruz for
president Chris Kyle foundation
Breitbart and steven crowder yours truly
it was actually on a manual list to
throttle and so I called up this guy who
I didn't know at the time I was told
would be a good lawyer for this and he
said yeah this looks really bad and we
settled out of court with them and they
effectively admitted that this was
happening though all the while right
before it was leaked and discovered
everyone well it's just algorithmic well
now we know it's an algorithmic so
you've caught them line before it's
really hard to know you know yeah
Stephen forgive me do you know what the
most depressing part of this is or
equally depressing it's not more than
pressing by the way I just want to
restate 80 I didn't state this I'm so
I'm stating it for the first time I'm
restating it from previous visits with
you 80 it is now up to 80 the number of
Prager University videos that are
restricted on YouTube yeah I think ours
is about 12 to 15 that are not
restricted that's it everything else on
the hunt I think it's a thousand now
that now that the equally depressing
news yeah the New York Times today in an
opinion piece says this is an entirely
manufactured lie on the part of the
right that there is any censorship being
done on the Internet
a CNN just had a similar piece I tweeted
it I tweeted the CNN piece yeah I said
those of you who do not believe excuse
me who do not believe that the media
have earned the title fake news right
look at what CNN wrote about censorship
on the Internet no it's exactly right
and we just did that change my mind at
the White House and people started
quoting Donald Trump saying he said that
the the Free Press is the enemy of the
people I suppose I can he said fake news
is the enemy of the people if I'm not
back and
you're quoting Stalin and the thing is
they say the lady actually said well I
only know what I read and I watch and
sure enough it was you know all the
leftist sources and and that's what is
concerning you know I don't know if it
necessarily believed in regulating them
like public utilities but it's funny we
talk about net neutrality right and ISPs
and talk you have far more options most
people as far as Internet service
providers than you do in search options
right now are what PP there are three
main sites Google YouTube Twitter right
and that includes sorry Google Facebook
Twitter Google includes YouTube I can
probably pick from about five or six
different internet service providers in
our area and it's something that no one
real not no one people are starting to
talk about but it's every bit as much of
a monopoly duopoly I don't know if
Tripoli is a word my concerns with the
dishonest business practices because you
know your business and mine lives and
dies with understanding the rules and
freedom of the free exchange right for
people who argue well you know it's
private enterprise they could do what
they want and then that is a
conservative argument right but but
let's talk reality and I always give
this example if Delta Airlines said if
you walk on our plane with the Wall
Street Journal I'm sorry we don't want
you on you can walk on with the New York
Times but not with the Wall Street
Journal after all it's a free it's right
it's free
i bethought last such independent
company they should have the right to do
that but but it's more severe on the
internet if you don't fly Delta you can
fly American or United or some other
airline right but if you don't go via
Facebook what are you going to do
yeah it's a good point though I don't
know that I've I don't know where my
loyalties would lie because they have
those delicious sugar biscottis on Delta
that you don't get anywhere else and I
don't know where to find them I've
looked at HomeGoods I cannot find those
cookies they are fantastic
damn you Delta all right we do have to
get going I know you have a hard out
today it is exodus god slavery and
freedom the rationale Bible of course
Prager you please go and support the
fight that Dennis Prager is fighting
right now he's been at the forefront for
a while mr. Prager thank you so much for
spending the time and I'll see you soon
doing Prager University
[Music]
and now for hopper proverbs sponsored
exclusively by mud club they said that
if you give a dog some cheated you feed
him for a day but if you give a dog a
cow I don't well I don't know how to
make chillies but if I diversify some
thumbs a Papa could figure it out just
on my club so Steven can give Harper
more cheese's because he has thumbs stay
tuned for more hopper proverbs sponsored
by mug Club
[Music]
louder with prouder Ranger panties buy
yours today at louder with prouder shop
calm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a combo dance that's called the
nonchalantly dying grounder drownded
Ronnie and in combination with the
Halloween to know and Halloween to guy
died in the car and he had enough we
read in the horn you know you you really
can't not hold your breath
no that's it's a really stupid mistake
to make I think before it I'll not hold
my breath I'll just pretend no no you
always hold your breath to you by the
way that was also there was a third part
to that dance I was concerned because I
didn't know if you could actually swim
can you quarter can you quarter not swim
sometimes I just doggy paddle seriously
though do you ever you are you not a
good swimmer
no I can swim okay okay but people on
your dad's side are they not good
swimmers no by the way thank you so much
to Dennis Prager into these are fists
for being on the program and next week
I'm going to be I should let you know
I'll be in Los Angeles actually doing a
Prager University
doing a fireside chat with Dennis Prager
and I'll be doing a the full hour show
with Ben Shapiro full week Nick and then
we'll be back here Thursday so we'll
have some clips there we'll have a John
Stossel for people who are not mug Club
members up on Saturday killer and then
we'll also we might have Daniel Cormier
in third chair next week as far as I
know cuz by the way raise your fist his
dad has actually been sick and I asked
him all ferrites that I can talk about
that so that's why he hasn't been in
third chair and so we appreciate my mood
coming and filling in on short notice
it's a very long flight for him to make
that just for them on short notice but
you know Corey might be in third chair
so I don't want to put him in a
compromising position have to trot him
out to apologize an ESPN so busy really
really looking forward to it and you
know they're obviously there been some
changes that we're making here to grill
that we've talked about we're moving
into a new studio you've been seeing us
do more super videos and ever even idea
quarterblack was there in Washington DC
and it was a you know for us it was a
four hour flight out there it was a
couple hours to set up scope it out get
set up there at the White House 104
degree heat I think with the heat index
is is it's called heat index is that
what it is a heat index
something it's it feel really hot yeah
it felt really really hot index we were
out there taping for about three and a
half hours tear down
and then go have lunch write down or
notes everything you saw actually was
taped and was actually uploaded within
24 hours yeah went there traveled to DC
taped it edited it cut it that's
redundant edited it cut cut as a part of
editing and got it up within 24 hours
because we know that people are really
looking forward to it and thanks by the
way to the the reddit the subreddit
forms I think the conservative subreddit
in the Donalds subreddit people who
really enjoyed it but man it was a lot
of work you were probably pretty spent
when you came back yeah yeah I crashed
yeah I can imagine the plane when I
guess now otherwise if he had John
Denver situation but it was it's it's
it's a it's a lot of work and to give
you an idea that the reason it's
worthwhile and sometimes I think I've
kind of struggled with this and I know
I've talked about this before when we we
did SMU let me kind of rewind there was
a day actually where I had to go back
out to DC not long ago did this exact
same thing to do the yeah an American
Foundation conference and at this point
some things had changed where we were
just working through the week so this
was a Friday so we were taping a show
that day taping some kind of a big
sketch that they don't know exactly what
it was and then had to hop on a flight
get out there I landed at the airport 30
minutes before I supposed to be on stage
it was an hour drive so I got up on
stage about a half-hour late because it
was the only amount of time it was the
only way we could possibly make it work
it was the only flight we could take
did that show for an hour and a half and
then flew back and and I don't say this
because it's not that it's impressive in
any way what it is is a lot of people
here than work particularly like
reasonably going to DC every time I
think DC I think exhaustion to the brink
of exhaustion doing these things and I
hope that you guys see these changes
we're making a really to really looking
to to make sure that we honor the dollar
you spent with us we tell we don't take
it lightly we do not take it lightly
that not not only people who support us
at Mudd Club because in others you know
100 there are hundreds of patreon is out
there for as long as patron allows these
places to exist but to actually invest
in what we do with MUC live and watch
The Daily Show and join the CR TV
network it means a lot to us not only
that but your viewership when people
come up and I tried I always ask people
if I can read their letter
sometimes people say no sometimes people
say yes this was actually a letter that
I got while I was up that yeah
conference so that day I was exhausted I
didn't want it there's a
part of me that before I got in the
plane I was thinking is there any way to
get out of this and actually Johnny boy
the unsung hero got in a plane with me
and went out there and after I performed
it yeah and I think he can find the
video online we were taking pictures and
we had to catch a flight back and there
was a girl there were a couple of girls
who had some personal messages one of
whom was an ex-muslim she hasn't
responded so I don't know that I can use
her email but there was a young woman
who was who was crying quite a bit and
so I know yeah for being really
respectful I know we've got to move this
through because I don't want to take
pictures and we were trying to take
group pictures but I could see she was
distraught you know sometimes at these
shows you have people who come up and
it's just they want to give you the life
story just because they want to take a
picture and put on Instagram or like
that guy in Austin with the change my
mind remember yo Gris no pay but this
lady um lady young woman was was was
crying and so Allah say give me a minute
and I spoke with her and she sent me an
email so it was just titled she titled
it the crying girl and she wrote I just
this is why we do what we do and this is
why we're really trying to move us
onward and upward as powerfully as
possible because we do this show it's
it's it really is a lot more than
ourselves it really is we saw at SMU
these people that we really do feel like
we're a part of something greater than
ourselves and it's always hard to try
and to try and juxtapose that with you
know balance to try and spend time with
my family people here to try and make
sure that we we know we're putting out
the best product possible that we've
done everything that we can do but that
we're also not spreading ourselves too
thin and that's why we're still hiring
more people and we're growing and moving
into new place so this is what she wrote
I wanted to thank you so much for being
genuinely kind to me Friday night at
NCSC I see I feel weird reading any
compliments toward me on-air from this
letter but you know who you are crying
girl said you don't know how much that
meant to me I thought I should explain a
bit of why I was crying that night I'm
terrible with endings with the
realization that the conference was over
I came to realization that I will never
be able to tell my grandfather about any
of it you see my grandfather was the
first one to introduce me to the
conservative movement I got involved in
politics and more specifically EF
because of him he passed away in January
of this year and it has been one of the
hardest losses I've experienced
I'm Curtin Lee a rising senior at the
University of blank I'll withhold that
majoring in public policy
and I don't think I ever would have
ended up here without I've been
attending Yap conference and since I was
a freshman in high school and I always
looked forward to talking with my
grandfather about all the speakers I'd
heard from and the lessons I'd learned
his excitement and smiles every time
kept me going I knew when I went back
home I wouldn't be able to I was dealing
with the realization that my number-one
influencer in my life and the man I
looked up to was no longer here
you've always inspired me and my little
brother she writes some complimenting
things about my comedy here which I'll
withhold because I'll feel awkward but
she likes it so that's good so one
person does screw your YouTube comments
if I take you more seriously if you were
dressed like a genie don't thank you
once again for not only stopping for a
picture with me but for being concerned
and giving me this opportunity to email
you you have no idea how much my brother
and I look up to you thank you for
taking the time out of your busy
schedule to care god bless you and your
family this is one of those things where
you can read this and I know I've seen
people read this and then they exalt
themselves or you could read this and be
incredibly humbled now for me this is
something I've struggled with we talked
about this with Jordan Peterson I read
this and I get anxiety because it puts a
face to the fact that we actually have
an impact that we have an influence out
there for better or worse and I've got
to take that seriously I've got to
balance that with obviously trying to be
entertaining and obviously trying to
deliver what people have have come here
for while also understanding that people
are paying attention in people's minds
and hearts are being changed by what we
do not only would change my mind but
with every episode that we do it's a
really weird feeling and you've probably
to give you an analogy that might make
sense you've probably felt this if ever
you've had a child or a nephew or even a
little cousin who you saw copying you
you ever do that you ever do something
bad and a little kid you see them copy
you would say a bad word or do something
bad you like oh my gosh I better I
better really make sure that I that I
tread carefully here because there are
copycats monkey-see monkey-do not to
that degree I don't mean that you people
are copycats I want people to be
originalist when you go out there I
really do I'm hoping that there are more
people on YouTube I'm hoping that they
don't silences so you know they can't
silence us all they can silence us
singularly that's the issue and I want
to see more people out there I hope
there's more competition for consumers
but this was three weeks ago
going out to DC and I was tired then
everyone here was tired then so before
went out to to change my mind I know a
lot of people weren't really
forward to doing it it was tiring it was
exhausting it was a lot of work it was
carrying a lot of heavy stuff it was hot
and I just wanted to say it was entirely
worth it so I'm incredibly appreciative
crying girl as you titled yourself in
the email I really do appreciate its
emails like this that really do keep us
going on and everything that you see is
a byproduct of that everything worth
while doing is hard if it weren't
everyone would be doing doing I know
that sounds like a bumper sticker we've
talked but it's absolutely true if it
weren't hard everyone would be doing it
this isn't easy what we do not a quarter
blacks job is not easy my moods job was
not Gerald's job is not any Johnny boy
sound guy two words up none of their
jobs are easier everyone would be doing
this we cannot I say this humbly we
cannot do this without you
people don't join my club people don't
tune in people don't watch we don't get
people like this who send these letters
guess what we go away it's absolutely
true it's the opposite of a boycott
you're by caught your support is what
allows us to do this and that's why I
owe you always hear me say we you hear
me say our you hear me say the team the
team isn't just the people here who work
here it really is you people watching
people commenting people liking people
sharing that's the only reason we're
able to do what we do believe me it is
not lost on me or anyone here and that's
why we're really hoping to bring you
some some new and great things this
coming year and hopefully coming years
if you'll have us always if you'll have
us see you next week Daniel Cormier I'll
be in LA - at
[Music]
you